it's really very very dull when after
all these years in public life you're
known for two things Ray-Ban sunglasses
and chocolate chip ice cream
very dull president
Dole 2024 I mean that doesn't make a
great campaign slogan so Biden's trying
to fire up the radical left today rumors
are buzzing that he'll announce his
re-election bid next Tuesday with just a
low-key video and today he was sucking
up to the squad by ordering every
government agency to make environmental
justice a priority
every Federal agency must take into
account environmental and health impacts
on communities and the work to prevent
those negative impacts environmental
justice will be the mission of the
entire government in two years we're
making real progress in the most
ambitious environmental justice agenda
in history
with this executive order we'll go in
further so we all know Biden is taking a
page from aoc's Playbook she's back
pushing for the green New Deal watch
we said we are not going to take crumbs
and we're not going to settle for that
that we need bold big climate action and
we need it now these bills not only stop
climate change they tackle the
intersecting crises of climate economic
inequality and racial justice but it's
not the far left Biden Easton press only
26 percent of Americans want the guy to
run again judge I mean that's that's a
Whopper yeah 26 of America 26 percent of
Americans want him to run again
um 56 percent of Americans say that they
are unlikely to support his bid in any
event and here's the thing he has gone
to the right he has done what AOC wants
but AOC could ever get enough and for
her to call this crumbs is ridiculous
because the truth is in the inflation
reduction act they had
369 billion dollars to tackle climate
change okay and in the infrastructure
bill they had another the 50 billion
dollars to tackle climate change and now
she wants another 900 billion which puts
us well over a half a trillion dollars
and I kind of feel like this is like the
coven school money like you never know
where it's going and you never know
who's getting it and now they're talking
about some kind of a a credit system uh
where you have an environmental
scorecard you get credits for what you
do or what you don't do but here's the
one question that I I just want to pause
it now
ah look I believe in fossil fuel and oil
and gas and I like my gas stove and I'm
not cooking on an electric stove and I
like my car okay but there there are
there's nuclear energy and there's other
kinds of winds and solar and all that
but apparently even things like the the
the wind energy doesn't have a zero
impact on the environment and so you
know they've got to at least make it
clear that everything has an impact on
the environment and whether or not these
whales that are that are you know
pushing up on the on the seashore are
the result of some kind of problem in
the ecosystem in the ocean I don't know
but you know they can't make it like
it's all this and none of that because
in the end we don't even know the extent
of the impact people think if you plug
in an electric car that's it it doesn't
impact the environment of course it does
well Greg I I questioned us in your
sincerity I mean they allowed the people
in East Palestine to just rot president
still hasn't been there the environment
is totally destroyed there they claim
that it's it's safe to breathe the air I
went down there I couldn't breathe when
I was there the animals can't even drink
the water there
they care about the environment but they
do nothing for those people
they don't look like the people they
care about they're the wrong they're the
wrong type of person if you look at the
name at the words that they're using now
environmental justice scorecard which
will be run by a federal Chief
environmental justice officer what does
that mean what is environmental justice
mean AOC laid it out perfectly the
environment is now tied to racism which
is what they did with the ESG
environmental social governance it's a
scorecard another scorecard that takes
measures on how companies act
responsibly so they marry they marry the
environment to race because it couldn't
be believed alone the numbers weren't
working the projections weren't working
but you know it works being scared have
being called a racist so environmental
justice if you do not agree with it if
you don't swallow the climate agenda if
you don't agree with AOC you probably
don't just hate the planet you probably
hate non-white people as well and the
consequences of that talked about it
before with every aspect of life uh
being filled with racism or Injustice
the roads are racist we found out this
week uh pollution is racist we just
found out cheap energy fossil fuels
that's racist because it hurts uh
non-white people uh if if you don't want
to be looted that's racist too because
looting is mere a redefinition of
Justice uh basically you're telling
people that they can you're sanctioning
crime you're sanctioning riots that's
why the politicians in Chicago said as
much and said that this was their way of
evening this score because when you tell
everybody and you program their brain
with this language that the world sucks
and it's this group of people behind it
now it's in climate now it's in climate
what next Geraldo is Greg right on this
yes uh he is in in part but you have to
go beyond it though uh Lawrence it's
it's not environmental justice it's
environmental Injustice and I would
submit that poor whites are the
minorities along with the uh poor blacks
and Hispanics that live near these uh
chicken processing plants these meat
processing plants these these toxic
waste dumps these sewage plants why did
they take care of the poor whites in
East Palestine
I I do not defend their action there as
a as a resident of Ohio it was it was
horrible uh they were very inept they
did send the EPA director I'm not going
to defend them at all though they
finally got around to it the railroads
uh have a problem that's much deeper
than democrat or republican there's a
derailment every day someplace in this
country we've got to deal with but I
here's here's my point my political
point
you saw the energy of gen z uh in the uh
the recent election in uh Wisconsin and
then other uh other political activities
if the Republicans don't buy into
fighting environmental or environmental
Injustice they're going to motivate
those kids to vote the other way they're
going to drive the Gen Z out of the
Republican Party forever so we have to
be cognizant not just uh we need the
world to be able to sustain it I I hear
you but Martha this is not a you're out
there I'm out there with voters it's not
a top issue for them this is not the
issue so the reason why I don't think
Republicans are talking about this is
because people want cheaper gas prices
they want the price of eggs to come down
they're not talking about making the
price of energy go up well what this is
talking about is making government even
larger right which costs more oh yeah
you develop a new agency right to create
the office of environmental justice we
already have an EPA we have an
environmental agency it has it costs 12
billion dollars a year it has 17
000 employees that are part of the
Environmental Protection Agency then we
have a doj if you want just Justice
right we've got they pay 69 billion
dollars was their budget for this year
they have 115
000 employees so if you can't find
someone who's already in the government
to solve the problems that you're seeing
uh you got another problem creating
another office another agency is very
unlikely to solve any of the problems
that they address and you know with
regard to these you know testing the
effectiveness of these plans like the
wind turbine issue the Pentagon is now
the most recent agency that's sounding
an alarm about the wind turbines they're
saying that it conflicts with military
operations wow in a number of places we
know that there's this question about
whales and the health of the oceans we
know that the fishermen are also
impacted negatively by this and you know
you have to ask yourselves like are they
actually testing what works to make the
environment cleaner or are we creating
new problems where there weren't
problems in some cases it's all about
virtue not about getting things done hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else